Breaking Bad is one of the best shows in TV
history, and after five seasons, it all led
to an ending that people still talk about
today.
But if you need a helping hand to understand
that final episode, well then, let's cook.
Creator Vince Gilligan had one of the best
high-concept hooks for Breaking Bad that any
show has ever had.
As Gilligan put it:
"This is a story about a man who transforms
himself from Mr. Chips into Scarface."
The appeal of Breaking Bad is pretty simple
because it asks a question we've all probably
wondered at least once.
How far would a regular person, a Mr. Chips
type, go if they knew they were dying and
had to provide for their family?
With that theme in mind, it's easy to see
how Breaking Bad is about the American dream,
the idea that if you do good work, then the
people in charge will see your value and reward
you for your skills.
Of course, most people would prefer their
paychecks come from legitimate bosses and
not various criminal drug lords in the crystal
meth trade.
Not so for Walter White.
After all, the longer he stays in the game,
the higher he rises.
But the higher he rises, it gets harder and
harder for him to argue that he's just leaving
a nest egg for his family, and he transforms
from a sympathetic and unlikely anti-hero
into a full-fledged villain.
"Say my name."
"Heisenberg."
So we've spent a lot of time talking about
Walt, but what does the actual ending of Breaking
Bad mean?
Well, first we need to specify which ending
we're talking about.
Each of the final three episodes, "Ozymandias,"
"Granite State," and "Felina", can function
as a kind of ending for the show.
In the case of "Ozymandias," it's a poetic,
circular ending.
"My name is Ozymandias, king of kings!
Look on my works, ye mighty, and despair."
Walt betrays Jesse completely by giving his
former partner up to the white supremacists
he's been working with.
Worse still, he admits to Jesse that he watched
Jane die and did nothing.
"I watched her overdose and choke to death.
I could have saved her.
But I didn't."
But even before handing Jesse over to the
Nazis, Walt is indirectly responsible for
getting Hank, his DEA brother-in-law, killed.
And then Walt has to watch as Uncle Jack and
his white supremacist gang take away all his
earnings, except one single barrel of cash.
Walt then has to roll the barrel back towards
civilization, passing by the pair of pants
he lost in the very first episode.
When he tries to convince his family to flee
with him, his wife and son attack him, and
Walt kidnaps his infant daughter.
It's all of Walt's lies laid bare.
He chose an empire over his family, and like
the Shelley poem the episode is named after
says, no empire lasts forever.
Walt has the money to flee into a kind of
witness protection program for criminals,
but he's giving up the family that he pretended
to do so much for.
If "Ozymandias" is the "realistic" end to
Walt's journey, then "Granite State" is a
fitting punishment for the former meth kingpin.
Walt ends up in a remote cabin where his only
company, Ed "the Disappearer," comes by just
once a month to drop off supplies.
Even in the kind of purgatory that Walt lives
in, he's still not free of his cancer, and
he's constantly waiting for Ed to return with
chemotherapy drugs.
It's a fitting punishment for a man who pretended
to do everything he did out of loyalty and
family obligations.
Walt is so lonely that he ends up paying Ed
thousands of dollars just for an extra hour
of his time.
He's alive and rich but all alone.
Much like the characters of a different AMC
show, Walt is basically the walking dead.
The only thing that brings him out of his
mountain retreat is the possibility of passing
on his ill-gotten gains to his family.
Walt literally tries to buy his way back into
his son's affections, and of course, it doesn't
work.
However, he's given one last goal when he
sees his former colleagues Gretchen and Elliott
on television, downplaying Walt's contributions
to their company, Gray Matter Technologies.
It's reasonable that they would.
After all, it's not exactly good for a company's
stock to have a co-founder become a murderous
drug kingpin.
Walt, unsurprisingly, does not see their side
of things.
Instead, he thinks they're disrespecting him
by not giving him credit.
"Felina," the finale episode of Breaking Bad,
is basically a victory lap for Walt.
He gets to accomplish everything that he left
his mountain retreat to do.
He threatens Gretchen and Elliott into giving
all of his money to his family under the guise
of a charitable donation.
"Gretchen, would you mind?
I don't wanna lose any of it under the furniture.
Alright."
He kills all of the white supremacists that
stole his blue meth recipe.
Walt frees Jesse from slavery, and he even
gets a kind of closure with Skyler and his
infant daughter.
Plus, he poisons Lydia with a whole lot of
ricin, and he successfully evades the police
all the way to the end.
Even when he appears to die, it's on his own
terms.
He's not rotting of cancer but dying in the
arms of his true love, the chemistry lab that
produces his blue meth.
Walt is infamous, which as we know from The
Three Amigos, is when you're more than famous.
Combine all of these facts, and it's hard
to deny that this is Walter's perfect, inevitable
ending.
"Felina" might be Walt's fantasy, but it's
everyone else's nightmare.
Throughout the episode, Walt is a monstrous
presence.
He moves through scenes like a horror movie
slasher.
When he talks to Skyler, he appears like a
ghost, the scene is even blocked like a jump
scare.
When he brags to Lydia about how he poisoned
her drink, it's a moment that wouldn't be
out of place in a Final Destination movie.
Walt gets his victory lap in the final episode,
but it's only because he's chasing his enemies
around the track.
"I slipped it into that Stevia crap that you're
always putting in your tea."
"Oh my god."
Even when Jesse escapes the white supremacist
compound, finally free of Walt and his vindictive
torturers, he lets out a guttural scream straight
from The Texas Chainsaw Massacre.
If there's anyone in the show that knows what
kind of monster Walt was, it's Jesse.
When he drives out of the show, it's as viscerally
satisfying as seeing the final girl in a horror
movie survive the killer.
Walt starts Breaking Bad by telling his family
that he loves them, and that everything he
did was for their sake.
He ends the show hobbling out to the meth
shed to be with what he truly loves: his work,
his legacy.
It's clear that he was never really Mr. Chips.
Whatever falling out happened between him
and his partners before the show started was
a symptom of something deeper.
Walt's cancer was just an excuse for him to
be the power-hungry villain he'd always wanted
to be.
As Vince Gilligan once put it:
"We always say in the writers' room, if Walter
White has a true superpower, it's not his
knowledge of chemistry or his intellect, it's
his ability to lie to himself.
He is the world's greatest liar."
Walt lied to himself for so long that he believed
his own lies for most of the show.
He lied to the audience, too.
How much you want to believe that Walt was
a good man is dependent on how much you want
to believe his lies.
Was he a good man who "broke bad," or was
he always a twisted monster who finally got
the excuse to behave like Scarface?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.